hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions here's a problem
from a previous video start out with the
rectangle whose sides are 4 and 8 draw a
semicircle and then draw a diagonal of
this rectangle what's the area of this
shape in red I've solved for this in a
previous video and in this video I'm
going to ask for you to solve for a
general formula in terms of R where the
rectangle has side lengths R and 2 R and
R is the radius of the semicircle I
think Tony has lair for devising the
solution method which made me think of
this general case if you'd like to give
the problem a try pause the video right
now and when you're ready keep watching
the video for a solution
[Music]
so how can we solve for the area this
red shape in previous videos here's the
method I use I said the red shape is
equal to the area of this right triangle
minus the area of this green shape minus
the area of this purple shape it's easy
to solve for the areas of this right
triangle and this green shape but the
area of this purple shape is a pretty
involved calculation it's not impossible
but they're just many steps so rather
than going through that method I'm going
to show you a solution from Tony has
lured that I think is really great we
start out with a coordinate system where
the lower left corner is the origin this
point is R comma zero this point is zero
comma R the semicircle has this equation
and the diagonal has an equation y is
equal to x over two will now focus on
this square let's find the coordinates
of this point in order to do that we'll
solve for the intersection of the
semicircle and the line y is equal to x
over 2 we'll do some algebra and we'll
end up with the quadratic equation we
can factor this equation and we get two
solutions but we want the solution where
X is between 0 and R so the solution we
want is X is equal to 2 R over 5 since Y
is equal to x over 2 this means Y is
equal to R over 5 and we figured out
that this coordinate is 2 R over 5 comma
R over 5 now let's draw this line this
line is key to solving this problem we
can now solve for the area of this red
shape as follows it'll be the area of
this blue triangle plus the area of this
green right triangle minus the area of
this circular sector so we only need to
solve for the areas of three shapes and
as we'll show these will be pretty
routine calculations so let's get
started with this blue triangle in order
to do that we need to solve for the base
of this blue triangle so let's solve
the slope of this line so that we can
figure out where it intersects the
x-axis since this line passes through R
comma R and this blue point we
calculated we can calculate its slope is
equal to 4/3 now we have the equation of
a line will be y is equal to 4/3 X plus
some y-intercept
we know that this line passes through
the point R comma R so we substitute in
that point we can then solve for B we
now want to know what happens when y is
equal to 0 so we get the coordinate that
X is equal to R over 4 and that'll be
this point right here we can now use
this coordinate to figure out the area
of this blue triangle its base will be R
over 4 and its height will be R over 5
as you can see from the coordinates of
the blue point so the area of this
triangle will be 1/2 times its base
times its height and that simplifies to
be R squared over 40 we now want the
area of this green triangle well we
pretty much have each of its dimensions
we can calculate that it's height is
equal to R because it goes from R comma
0 to R comma R and we can calculate its
base which goes from R over 4 to R so
this will be 3 R over 4 it's area will
be 1/2 its base times its height which
simplifies to be 3 R squared over 8 now
for the next part we'll need to know
this angle theta right here notice this
is a right triangle and its base is 3 R
over 4 and it's adjacent side is R so
theta will be equal to the inverse
tangent of 3/4 we now need to solve for
the area of this circular sector the
area of a circular sector is one-half R
squared times the angle of that sector
we know that the radius of this circular
sectors R so this area will be R squared
over 2 multiplied by the central angle
which is the inverse tangent of 3/4 so
we now have a simple equation for the
area of this red shape it'll be the sum
of the areas of these two triangles mine
the area of this circular sector we just
need to work through a little bit of
algebra and simplify and we get a simple
formula it's 2 R squared over 5 minus R
squared over 2 times the inverse tangent
of 3/4 it might be a little easier to
put it in this form if you want to put
it on a calculator it'll be R squared
multiplied by the quantity 0.4 minus 0.5
times the inverse tangent of 0.75 and
that's it we figured out a general
formula regardless of the value of R we
can always get the area of this red
shape whether R is equal to 4 R is equal
to 10 R is equal to 73 or R is equal to
any value that you want incredible it's
really great when geometry works out so
simply I hope you enjoyed this problem
thank you for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you